yeah I was in a car accident it was
crazy but how bad no no I didn't nothing
really happened we were just lucky like
yeah we were going to Depeche Mode
concert nice on the way back home 1991
violator tour whoever wanted was here in
my arms and we're going and Rick
Camacho's tires were bald and it's
raining you know cars are coming this
way we're going
and it just hydroplane kept going into
their Lane and I saw this truck coming
oh no and I go oh my God I grabbed my
pillow and I went behind Jacobs Jacob
was in the passenger seat and I just I
remember it chick forever here I was
like
oh
my God
oh and all of a sudden it was just
silence oh that's and I looked over and
Jacob had like blood on his head no and
Rick was like oh my God oh my God and
the car was smashed right up to their
legs like